♪
>> Greg: SATURDAY THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS HEADED TO D.C. IN
SUPPORT OF PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THIS SEA OF TRUMP FLAGS MADE
THEM TARGETS.
THEY EVEN HAD FIREWORKS CHUCKED
AT THEM FROM DINERS.
>> FIREWORKS, FIREWORKS!
>> Greg: AFTER MOST LAW-ABIDING
MARCHERS LEFT THE RALLIES,
CHILDREN WERE TERRIFIED, PEOPLE
BEATEN, THEIR BELONGINGS RIPPED
FROM THEM.
AMONG THE ATTACKERS, A CHILD SEX
OFFENDER AND A JOURNALISM
STUDENT.
AT LEAST THE LEFT’S TENT IS A
BIG ONE.
THESE VIDEOS ENDED UP ONLY ON
TWITTER.
THE MEDIA IGNORED THEM SAYING
THEY LEFT OUT CONTEXT.
WHAT IS THE CONTEXT THAT
JUSTIFIES BEATING UP INNOCENT
PEOPLE?
THAT THEY DISAGREED WITH THE
THUGS?
REMEMBER, TRUMP IS HITLER SO
VIOLENT IS ACCEPTED.
THE A.P. SAID TRUMP SUPPORTERS
WERE THE PERPS BECAUSE THEY
SUPPORT TRUMP.
DID ANYONE HARASS THE LEFT?
WE DON’T DO THAT.
ASIDE FROM THE RIOTS, THE MEDIA
SAYS THEY’RE PEACEFUL.
WHAT HAVE THEY THOUGHT THEY LOST
NOW?
THAT’S EASY.
CITIES WOULD HAVE BURNED, PEOPLE
WOULD HAVE DIED, HENCE THE
BOARDED UP BUILDINGS.
THE FACT THAT MEDIA IGNORES THIS
REVEALS THEIR COMPLICITY.
WHILE BLACK LISTING PEOPLE LIKE
YOU AND ME.
BEYOND WHAT IS OBVIOUS IS THE
GAME.
WHILE THE MEDIA STICKS THEIR
HEAD IN THE SAND AND THEIR BUTTS
IN THE AIR AND ON CAMERA.
I THINK WHAT WE LEARNED, NOT ALL
VICTIMS ARE CREATED EQUAL.
YOU CAN HIT A TRUMP SUPPORTER.
>> Dagen: YEAH, THE
DEHUMANIZATION AND THE
DEMONIZATION OF TRUMP SUPPORTERS
AND CONSERVATIVES.
NOW, THIS HAS BEEN HAPPENING IN
UNIVERSITY CLASSROOMS AND BE I
THE MEDIA.
SO WHEN SOMEBODY ON THE LEFT,
ANTIFA, WHATEVER YOU WANT TO
CALL THEM SEES A TRUMP
SUPPORTER, THEY DON’T SEE A MOM
OR A DAD OR SON OUR DAUGHTER,
THEY SEE THE ENEMY, THE RACIST,
THE NAZI.
THEIR MEANS JUSTIFY -- THE END
JUSTIFIES THE MEANS THAT THEY’RE
PUSHING.
IT’S VIOLENT.
I DON’T KNOW HOW YOU REVERSE
THAT.
IT NEEDS TO BE A COLLECTIVE PUSH
BY EVERYBODY WHO WEARS A
MICROPHONE BY EVERYBODY IN THE
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM TO
BASICALLY -- I DON’T KNOW --
UNITY.
>> Greg: YEAH.
>> Dagen: THAT’S THE WORD OF THE
DIAGONAL.
>> Dagen: JUAN, BY DEFINITION,
ISN’T PUNCHING SOMEBODY OVER A
POLITICAL
POLITICAL BELIEF IS A HATE
CRIME?
>> Juan: YEAH.
YOU TAKE A SNIPPET OF AN
INCIDENT AND DON’T EXPLAIN TO
PEOPLE WHAT HAPPENED BEFORE OR
AFTER.
THAT’S WHAT THEY MEAN BY
CONTEXT.
IF SOMEBODY IS PROVOKING
SOMEBODY OR SOMEBODY HITS
SOMEBODY AND THEN YOU HAVE A
SNIPPET OF VIDEO AND SAY LOOK,
THAT PERSON -- THAT’S --
>> Greg: I’D SAY PROVOKED.
>> Juan: TOTALLY MISREPRESENTED.
DOESN’T TELL THE TRUTH.
THAT’S WHY A LOT OF PAPERS AND
TV STATIONS SAY WE TONIGHT HAVE
THE WHOLE STORY OR IN THE CASE
OF A.P. THAT YOU MENTIONED, THE
A.P. SAID THESE PEOPLE HAD BEEN
PROVOKED.
>> Greg: WITH WHAT?
>> Juan: YOU HAVE TO CHECK OUT
WHAT HAPPENED IN ORDER TO HAVE A
CLEAR SENSE NONBIAS SENSE OF
WHAT HAPPENED.
BUT I THINK THAT YOU HAVE PEOPLE
ON BOTH SIDES THAT ARE BEING
PROVOCATEURS IN THAT SITUATION.
>> Greg: THE FAMILIES.
>> Juan: THE PROUD BOYS --
>> Greg: OH, THAT ELDERLY
COUPLE.
THEY’RE EASTING THE BREAST OF
CHICKEN IN A PROVOCATIVE WAY.
>> Dana: I CAN’T IMAGINE BEING
AT A RESTAURANT, EATING OUTSIDE
BECAUSE THAT’S WHAT YOU’RE
SUPPOSED TO DO AND FIRECRACKERS
COMING OFF.
I WOULDN’T RECOVER.
>> Greg: YOU DON’T LIKE NOISE
ANYWAY.
>> Dana: YEAH, I DON’T LIKE
NOISE.
>> Greg: WHAT’S THE SOLUTION
HERE?
>> Dana: THE NOISE?
>> Greg: IN GENERAL.
YOU’RE DRESSED IN WHITE.
YOU’RE AN EXPERT.
>> Dana: PART OF IT IS THAT --
RELATIVELY SPEAKING, THERE’S A
LOT OF -- A LOT OF PEACEFUL
MARCHING THAT WENT ON.
THE TRUMP FOLKS THAT GOT DOWN
THERE FOR THE MAGA MARCH, IT
WAS -- THAT WAS MOSTLY PEACEFUL.
YOU HAD THE VIOLENCE.
WE AMPLIFY IT BECAUSE YOU PLAY
IT AND YOU SEE IT ON SOCIAL
MEDIA.
IT’S HAPPENING.
I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
EVERYBODY HAS TO DO AND THE
HOLIDAY SEASON MIGHT BE A GOOD
TIME TO DO THAT ESPECIALLY AT
HOME BECAUSE OF THE CORONAVIRUS,
YOU HAVE TO THINK ABOUT WHAT
KIND OF EXAMPLE DO YOU WANT TO
LEAVE?
LEAVE THE EXAMPLE THAT YOU WANT
FOR YOUR COMMUNITY AND YOUR
FAMILY FIRST.
START THERE.
RATHER THAN NATIONALIZING EVERY
ISSUE.
>> Greg: IT’S LIKE A LANGUAGE
THAT THEY DON’T UNDERSTAND.
>> Dana: AND THERE WAS A PIECE
POSTED ONLINE WHERE BIDEN AND
HARRIS REALLY NEED TO STEP UP
HERE AND TO SAY SOMETHING.
OBVIOUSLY GOING TO SAY THAT
TRUMP DOES, TOO.
I GET THAT.
BIDEN DIDN’T SAY ANYTHING TODAY
UNTIL HE WAS ASKED.
HE COULD HAVE SAID SOMETHING
SATURDAY NIGHT.
THAT WOULD HAVE HELPED.
>> Greg: JESSE, LAST WORD TO
YOU.
>> Jesse: I FOUND IT FUNNY THAT
JUAN SAID THE MEDIA NEEDS
CONTEXT.
THE CLIPS MIGHT NOT SHOW THE
WHOLE STORY.
WHEN HAS THAT STOPPED THE MEDIA?
REMEMBER THE COVINGTON BOY?
IF YOU’RE GOING TO FIGHT, FIGHT
LIKE A MAN.
SQUARE UP WITH SOMEONE YOUR OWN
AGE THAT ALSO WANTS TO THROW AND
GO.
WHEN I LOOK AT THESE CLIPS AND
THEY’RE NOT 30-SECOND CLIPS,
THEY’RE TWO-MINUTE,
THREE-MINUTE, FOUR-MINUTE CLIPS.
SO I’M SEEING PEOPLE GET SUCKER
PUNCHED FROM BEHIND.
YOU CAN SEE WOMEN, THE ELDERLY
GETTING ATTACKED.
THEY’RE COMING IN WITH SWEET WE
MONDAYS.
>> Greg: PUNCHED A WOMAN IN THE
BACK OF THE HEAD.
I DON’T KNOW WHAT CONTEXT WOULD
BE REQUIRED TO MAKE THAT OKAY.
>> Jesse: THE OLDERLY WOMAN
DOESN’T WANT ANY TROUBLE.
IT’S WHAT YOU SAID AND WHAT YOU
SAID IN THE MONOLOGUE.
IF YOU SPEND FOUR YEARS TELLING
PEOPLE THAT TRUMP AND HIS
SUPPORTERS ARE NAZIS AND WHITE
SUPREMACISTS, THAT GIVES THIS
MOB A LICENSE TO LIGHT THESE
PEOPLE UP.
THIS IS LIKE WORLD WAR II FOR
THEM AGAIN.
THEY FEEL GOOD ABOUT WHAT
THEY’RE DOING.
THEY FEEL LIKE THEY’RE CLEANING
UP THE STREET.
IF NOTHING EVER HAPPENS, THERE’S
NO PENALTIES.
THEN THAT IS FINE.
IF YOU SAY A MAGA HAT IS
EQUATABLE THING TO A SWASTIKA,
DOESN’T MATTER IF AN OLD WOMAN